♪ DROVE MY CHEVY TO THE LEVY
WITH THE LEVEE WAS DRY ♪♪
>> Tucker: IT'S BEEN A MOST
YEAR SINCE'S BE 21 WAS NEVER ONE
TRANCE IN AMERICA, BUT STILL
UBIQUITOUS.
EVERYWHERE.
SOMETIMES THE LYRICS EVEN GET
REFERRED TO ON CABLE NEWS SHOWS.
>> THAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S POSITION.
IF YOU'RE NOT SOLD YET, IF YOU
SUSPECT THERE ARE SOME LINKS
MISSING FROM THAT LOGIC CHAIN,
NANCY PELOSI HAS SOMETHING
PEOPLE A DENSE CLUSTER OF
FAMILIAR PHRASES DESIGNED TO
CONVEY THE IMPRESSION THAT WERE
FOUND FOR THINKING IS TAKING
PLACE.
LIKE THAT OLD DON McLEAN SONG,
"DROVE MY CHEVY TO THE LEVEE BUT
THE LEVEE WAS DRY."
DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING, BUT IT
KIND OF MOVES YOU ANYWAY.
>> Tucker: THEN WE STARTED
THINKING ABOUT IT, AND WE
REALIZE MAYBE THAT IS NOT FAIR.
"AMERICAN PIE"'S LYRICS MAY MEAN
SOMETHING.
TO FIND OUT, WE GO TO THE MAN
WHO WROTE THEM.
PROBABLY THE MOST FAMOUS
SONGWRITER IN THIS COUNTRY, DON
McLEAN JOINS US TONIGHT.
MR. McLEAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I WATCH YOUR SHOW OFTEN.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS A QUESTION EVERY PERSON
WHO HAS EVER DRIVEN ON AN
AMERICAN INTERSTATE HAS ASKED
HIM OR HERSELF.
WHERE IS THE LEVEE, AND WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN?
WHAT DO THE LYRICS MEAN?
>> WELL, CAN I JUST TAKE A
MOMENT AND EXPLAIN, THERE ARE
MANY POEMS AND SONGS IN FOLK
MUSIC, CERTAINLY, THAT ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY, EXACTLY PROSAIC.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE POETRY.
BUT I HAVE AN IDEA -- I HAVE NO
IDEA FOR A BIG SONG ABOUT
AMERICA, AND I DIDN'T WANT TO
WRITE "THIS LAND IS YOUR LAND,"
OR SOME SONG LIKE THAT.
I CAME UP WITH THIS NOTION THAT
POLITICS AND MUSIC FLOW PARALLEL
TOGETHER, FORWARD, THROUGH
HISTORY.
'S OF MUSIC YOU GET IS RELATED
SOMEHOW TO THE POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS GOING ON.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> AND IN THE SONG
"AMERICAN PIE," THE VERSES GET
SOMEWHAT MORE DIRE EACH TIME,
UNTIL YOU GET TO THE END.
BUT THE GOOD OLD BOYS ARE ALWAYS
THERE, SINGING, SINGING "BYE,
BYE, MISS AMERICAN PIE" COME
ALMOST LIKE FIDDLING WHILE ROME
IS BURNING.
THIS IS ALL IN MY HEAD.
IT STARTED TO TURN OUT TO BE
TRUE, BECAUSE YOU NOW HAVE A
KIND OF MUSIC IN AMERICA THAT IS
REALLY MORE SPECTACLE, IT WAS
MORE TO LIBERACE THAN IT DOES TO
ELVIS PRESLEY.
AND IT IS SOMEWHAT MEANINGLESS
AND LOUD AND BLOVIATING, AND
THEN WE HAVE THIS SORT OF
SPECTACLE IN WASHINGTON, THIS
KIND OF POLITICS, WHICH HAS
GOTTEN SO OUT OF CONTROL.
AND SO, THE THEORY SEEMS TO HOLD
UP.
AGAIN, IT WAS ONLY MY THEORY,
AND THAT IS HOW I WROTE THE
SONG.
THAT WAS THE PRINCIPLE BEHIND
IT.
>> Tucker: SO HE SET OUT TO
WRITE, AS YOU SAID, A BIG SONG
ABOUT AMERICA.
AND BOY, DID YOU SUCCEED.
50 YEARS LATER, YOU KNOW, IT'S
ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS SONGS
EVER WRITTEN IN ENGLISH, AND ONE
OF THE MOST RESILIENT AND
RESONANT.
WE ARE STILL LISTENING TO IT
EVERY DAY.
WHAT KIND OF REACTION DO YOU GET
FROM PEOPLE TO THE SONG NOW?
>> WELL, THE SONG HAS BEEN PART
OF THEIR LIVES NOW.
YOU KNOW, I'M PART OF THEIR
LIVES.
AND THE ALBUMS THAT I MADE IN
THE 1970s GO ALONG WITH THAT,
BUT OF COURSE, THE KINGPIN IS
THE SONG "AMERICAN PIE"
THE SONG "AMERICAN PIE."
AND REALLY, ALL ROADS LEAD TO
ROME IN MY SHOW.
I SING THE AMERICAN SONGBOOK,
SONGS THAT I'VE WRITTEN, WHETHER
IT IS "CASTLES IN THE AIR," "I
LOVE YOU SO," ALL OF THE
SONGS --
>> Tucker: "HUNTER WOOD."
>> ALL ROADS LEAD TO
"AMERICAN PIE" AT THE END,
USUALLY, AND IT'S A SUMMING UP
OF EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING ON.
I DON'T REALLY DO A SET, YOU
KNOW, I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
SO MANY YEARS, THAT I KIND OF
MAKE UP A NEW SHOW EVERY NIGHT.
BUT I JUST TELL YOU ONE THING
ABOUT YOURSELF THAT I'VE
NOTICED?
AND THAT IS THAT YOU DO
SOMETHING THAT NOBODY ELSE DOES.
YOU GET A GUEST ON, AND THEN YOU
ASK THEM A CORE QUESTION, AND I
THINK THAT NOBODY ELSE DOES
THAT.
IT'S A VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT
QUESTION, AND NINE TIMES OUT OF
TEN, THE GUEST CAN'T ANSWER IT,
WHICH MAKES IT VERY AMUSING AND
FUN, BECAUSE YOU DON'T GET INTO
THE WHOLE THING GOING EVERYWHERE
HE WANTS YOU TO GO, YOU MAKE
THEM COME TO THAT QUESTION, AND
THAT IS VERY PHILOSOPHICAL.
THAT IS SOCRATIC.
AND I LOVE THAT.
I THINK THAT IS TERRIFIC.
>> Tucker: I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
THE BASICS ARE WHAT MATTERS TO
ME.
I'M A VERY BASIC PERSON.
DON McLEAN, IT IS AN HONOR TO
HAVE YOU ON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THE NUMBER OF
TIMES I THOUGHT ABOUT YOU ALONE